all right so let's let's talk about the
apocalypse here it's it's well the
apocalypse by the wrong term for it
right because it is really not dystopian
nightmare a lot more accurate
I'm I'm actually kind of shocked that
it's been what like a month and a half
and we've gone from there is this thing
that's happening around the world to
literally don't leave your homes or will
arrest you yeah
don't go for a run or we'll arrest you
and you and and you may have to get a
card to prove the government has tested
your antibodies that's how crazy this
check out this video Gary you so that
this dude John Roberson tweeted is this
still is this really still about a virus
really because what I see here is an
individual doing their daily run and no
one anywhere near 20 foot distance
distancing suggestion not logg
suggestion a cop watts to enforce this
person doesn't want to be enforced upon
check out this video I'm gonna play this
for you it's actually kind of funny and
I'll have to describe it for those that
are just listening it is a beach
presumably in California it's playing
The Pink Panther music and there's a
digits jogging very lightly jogging here
comes the cop running full-speed gotta
gotta get them can't have someone out
there you know exercising the cops like
stop stop yeah the dudes ignoring nope
here comes the ninja music now that now
the jogger just goes full sprint and
he's gone cop can't catch him yeah look
he's gone he's looking back to he knows
it and it's funny though there's there's
something funny about a cop trying to
chase down a guy who was already running
yeah cuz it's like this dude who's
jogging clearly goes for runs every day
he's gonna be really fit he's probably
already stretched yep he's rockin it
think about how insane things have
gotten to where dudes is going for a jog
on the beach and the cops trying to get
him yeah that's that doesn't make any
sense to me like that's why I doing
wrong I mean I guess you know something
to do with the water
something protecting the quest that you
were alluding to no no I was gonna say
simple solution cops want to enforce
they want to be they want to tell you
what to do I guess yeah I almost don't
believe it maybe maybe it's because
we're seeing these videos from like
heavy you know liberal urban areas
because I feel like conservative areas
like the sheriff local cops yeah are
much less likely to do this well they're
not as authoritarian I don't think well
if you take a look at like the sanctuary
the to a sanctuaries that popped up in
West Virginia okay yeah when I'm not in
West Virginia in Virginia when Virginia
straight up said we're gonna ban all
these weapons all these local cops were
like nope it's like you're not gonna get
me to do it I swore an oath to defend
the Constitution not violate it that's
awesome but what do you think happens in
in New York the cops walk right up to
the young kid slam up against the wall
and frisk them in violation of the
fourth and second amendments yeah they
don't care in these areas yeah so that's
why I'm like look at this with this
person whatevs tweeted governor Whitmer
has banned us from growing our own food
this is effing insane yeah what is up
with this why can't people buy seeds
why not maybe they want civil war or
donors had a revolution what is wrong
with people growing their own food I
don't know you'd think that in this time
that would be a good idea this is
supplement your food by growing some of
your own done that's why this is why a
lot of people have been saying it can't
be about a virus can it yeah exactly and
that's weird
yeah because if it was you'd think
doesn't make sense to me maybe it's
because they're trying to foreskins
in the supply chain good they're trying
to say straight up know what you must
buy vegetables from jewel-osco or you
know the seizure aren't gonna yield you
know vegetables for a couple months at
least it's not like that people are
still gonna need to buy vegetables
overnight like course you know couple
months whatever I can't give you a
reason why this makes sense I don't I do
pin I can't either I never understand it
government bureaucracy makes no sense
because they're all dumb and they make
you know this look if I was gonna take
the the less conspiratorial approach
it's that these bureaucracies needs
govern officials can't plan for
everything so in their minds they're
thinking these stores shouldn't be
selling things like board games we
should just make it so they have to sell
food seeds aren't food technically yeah
so then this happens which is why
command economies and authoritarianism
doesn't work because now you got to
answer the question of why can't I go
some green beans in my backyard yeah
like well only essential items is food
essential it is but that's not food not
yet I don't know but when you see these
videos it's really easy to see why
people get off they go full
conspiratorial especially when you end
up with immunity cards for Americans are
being discussed yeah this is frightening
the proposal already being implemented
by German researchers is under
consideration in the United Kingdom and
Italy and they do it in China you got to
get a phone code they put on your phone
and they scan it to make sure that
you're you're approved and if you leave
the city you lose your approval it's the
world you want to live in no yeah this
is freaky man definitely not so this is
what we see from Daily Mail the
terrifying reports that tell the truth
about how lockdown ends there will be no
return to normal
America's top experts explain how the
nation faces mass digital surveillance
testing on an unimaginable scale or
recurring social distancing are they
trying to get Donald Trump reelected
because it's like good Trump just said
you know he gave a press conference
where he said he's got a very difficult
decision to make and he's worried he'll
make the wrong choice open up the
economy or keep it locked down there's
not gonna be mass testing and he wants
to get everything open as soon as
possible okay yeah you're gonna find
most Americans saying like yes please
know when you do stuff like this and you
send out your people saying
well hold on Trump's wrong we want to
make you all get tested by the
government and vaccinated management you
know mandatory vaccinations and then
we'll give you your papers people gonna
be like no I'll go with the other guy
yeah I have to wonder it's like is that
what they want what is this like the
Democrats doing this or something no I
don't know whoever is doing it I'm not
saying the Democrats okay I mean I
wouldn't be surprised yes because
they're ragging on Trump no matter what
he does so where Trump says let's open
up they're like ah but the end result is
is is what it's people saying give me
the guy who's telling me he's gonna get
things back to normal yeah it's crazy
how fast all this kind of started to
break down coronavirus immunity cards
yeah that's crazy we determine who is
allowed to re-enter the public there you
go you can never come back into public
unless you get your shot yes that's
that's scary that's the scary premise
check this out I'm not supposed to have
that much control over me I don't like
it yeah well how about this story should
we say this one and do it now we'll just
talk about no let's do it please this
guy in India it was that one on
coronavirus quarantine escaped naked and
then bit a woman on the neck killing her
ah maybe that's it
zombies yeah now here at here's here's
what they say he was mentally ill in a
history of mental illness uh-huh
you know and he was returning from Sri
Lanka what did they say they say uh
according local news the crazed man fled
his house naked and bit an 80 year-old
woman in the neck Indian cops that the
woman was admitted to a hospital on
Friday but died today after her
condition worsened a police spokesperson
told NDTV the accused manny Kendon has a
history of mental illness for which he
was treated in the madhurai back in 2010
on Friday he disrobed himself and ran
from his home he tripped and fell 100
meters from his home and targeted the
elderly woman who was sitting outside
her house according to the man's family
ever since manikandan returned from Sri
Lanka
he was stressed about losses in his
business suffered there and his business
over there and his mental illness
deteriorated so uh you know I was
thinking when I was reading this what
how would the how would the news media
react to a zombie apocalypse because we
don't we don't see that in in movies
what kind of luck in Shaun of the Dead
you had that bit where he's like
flipping channels oh yeah yeah no it's
like every
sentence is completed but it's like
telling him zombies are coming right and
then you have that one section where the
guys like stay in your homes and lock
your doors but I wonder what the news
reports would be like in the very early
stages of a zombie apocalypse mentally
ill man bites woman woman dies it's like
what we just read boom just like that
huh
zombie apocalypse but he was in
quarantine because he had coronavirus is
that what I understand I'm answered ace
that's what it says in the title
presumably maybe that's phase three of
the corona virus turns into a
blood-crazed throat not likely but the
reason I did pull that up is because a
lot of people like you saw on that tweet
is this really about the virus right and
so there's a lot of people who want to
like the immediate reaction is that
there's something else going on we don't
know about mm-hmm it could just be you
give the government power and they abuse
it it's a simple answer yeah but a lot
of people are looking at this and
they're saying things like this doesn't
add up why would they need to force
Medicaid us why would they need why
would they be arresting random people is
it a coincidence these cops are
arresting people on the beach for no
reason like when they said straight up
you can go exercise what's the
difference about that you know about the
beach what's going on yeah and if and if
something different was happening
they're not gonna tell you I mean check
look at what they were saying about the
report being given to trump in November
okay so this was a big story that was
reported
apparently some US intelligence you know
official came out and said it's not true
was never it was never report to the
White House so the best-case scenario
was we're looking at in January is
interesting January 29th the the Trump
administration received a memo saying
this is coming it could get really
really bad the left and the Democrat
types have said this is proof that Trump
knew and ignored it the same day Trump
formed the task force the same day he
got that letter saying he got the letter
he formed the task force okay and then
went on to start you know and two days
later ban Schieffelin banned travel from
China and then later on he definitely
did down flights at uh it's like a fluid
don't worry it'll be gone that seems to
me like evidence that he was trying to
stop before people from panicking yeah
but it's also a question of we're only
learning that they got this memo now
months later I'm curious what else they
knew and aren't telling us yeah whooping
now yeah about what's really going on
yeah you know because security they
wouldn't tell us right yeah they don't
want the general public to riot you know
it's like though I mean the whole seed
thing not being able to buy see it says
is weird you know that's really weird
it's it we it doesn't make sense you
know because I just don't bureaucracy
stupid people and why would that happen
it I feel like you're right when you
said like they want people to be need
need them they they want them to buy
into the supply chain and keep the
supply chain moving essentially you know
right go buy all the veggies from the
store so that the veggies that are
coming out or if the farmers are making
veggie still you know who knows because
some some farms are straight up closing
and stopping production some people like
are tweeting you know the government
doesn't want people to become
self-reliant they don't want to you know
they don't want us to get to a point
where everyone starts fending for
themselves growing some you know grows
their own garden yes adduce them on
their food going around red yeah not
even off the grid I mean you could live
in the suburbs you could live in Detroit
and be growing food yeah and that cuts
you off from the economy it makes you
hard to control it's a good point
whether it's about control I don't know
but they definitely want to control
things it's certainly feel it's about
control there's they're saying you
cannot buy seeds because they're
non-essential like everyone's at their
home what else what are people doing
they're working on their homes it's like
it makes sense to grow a garden that's
like it's great it's just an example of
the government being completely inept
and not understand anything about what
their policy is supposed to do like that
that would be great if that's all it is
it's just ignorance that would be
wonderful
I'll tell you what man we are getting
dangerously close to me getting outright
banned on every YouTube platform because
we're getting to the point where the law
is a complete violation of the
Constitution where the cops are trying
to arrest people for going for a jog you
know and there's a point where YouTube
will ban me for advocating for breaking
the law because at what point you know
so there's like a you know is this all
these lefties are mad at Infowars
apparently I think Owen Shroyer said
something like he's planning mass civil
disobedience of some sort
violating these these social quarantine
things because of how overzealous the
government and the place have become
okay well yeah at what point do you say
you can't do this look look I get it if
you say hey don't go outside we got a
pandemic right but you can go grocery
shopping you can take a walk you can go
exercise other arresting people if I
know but that's what they're saying
right they're saying you can go whatever
and like there's some places that people
are getting tickets for being in their
car just oh yeah yes yes all over and
getting citations for yeah like what why
they're there in a quarantine place like
how is a car not in quarantine you know
it's not like there was it was people
going to like a church right is that we
saw I'm not sure where they were going I
just told her that they were pulled over
and I was reading a story of people who
pulled up to like a church parking lot
and no one got out of their cars okay
and the cop left all the cars are giving
them tickets start threatening them it's
like but they're locked and you're
violating this is why people who think
it's not about the virus why would a cop
try and grab you if it was about not
spreading a virus these people are
either ridiculously stupid or they're
lying it's I never never attribute to
malice that which can be explained by
incompetence so maybe just a bunch of
[ __ ] cops or like do I'm gonna touch
somebody because I'm cuz they're not
supposed to touch people well I know in
New York that cops had to fill a certain
quota or else they either got knocked
pay or the whole department got less
money like the next quarter so it you
know is that what this is I don't know
like oh man we got to figure out any way
to fulfill our quotas I don't know I
don't think so everything's frozen so
they certainly can't be doing quotas
well what was it New York's got about 1
1 in 5 cops
who's out sick yeah and it's like I was
saying to it's like I don't I wouldn't
expect to see this in a more rural area
ok and it could be because the cops know
they're gonna be accountable to their
community yeah
whereas this cop he's like I don't know
you and I don't care I'm gonna chase you
down in the beach because you went for a
jog yeah what like seeing the seeing
that dude get arrested from the
paddleboarding thing makes no sense it
doesn't they're touching him yeah then
there was the dad who got arrested in
the park with his daughter playing
t-ball for cops show up breaking the
social quarantine in the social
distancing yeah and start touching the
guy so I
they're really really dumb like man yeah
you know I've seen people dumb as a box
of rocks I didn't know people could be
dumber than that yeah like oh oh there's
a pandemic I better go and touch a guy
who's minding his own business yeah Wow
what unless it's about something
different and I don't know what it could
or would be but this is why people are
certainly saying it on social media
because it feels like we're just being
fed nothing but lies nothing but lies
man I agree I don't know though dude I'm
uh I'm um
you know it there's there's up-and-downs
like we were just talking about this it
sometimes feels like things are getting
better yeah
we're hearing reports out of New York
that the ICU usage is like gone way way
down yeah projections were off not that
many people are gonna die
so yeah I'm hearing that from multiple
states they're like all of our numbers
are actually going down this hospital
was prepared and that looks like we're
not even gonna need it but do we get a
wave too good I mean if it is wave two
gonna be nearly as strong as wave one it
wasn't a Spanish flu it was worse
it was worse and worse yeah mm-hmm
because everyone let their guard down I
don't know I mean I can't tell you man I
can tell you this there comes a point in
time when these these you know here's
what here's what I said earlier that cop
broke the law yeah because that guy
don't know anything wrong you said the
video out of Philly where the guys
dragged out of the bus no yeah like a
bunch of the cops go on the bus he
wasn't wearing a mask and you don't have
to wear a mask there's nothing the the
bus actually it actually says unlike the
the bus ticket to getting things like no
one is required to merriment wear a mask
yeah and the cops don't care they were
like let's all go in and a huge group
and grab a random guy and drag him I
love a man arrest him or anything
seriously yeah there hold him off the
bus pulled him off there was one guy who
was wearing a mask but it wasn't a
surgical mask yeah and they're like no
masks get off and he's like well I have
this and is like I don't care get off
he's like okay like dude we can't we
can't we I'm surprised
so here's what I'm saying I'm gonna get
banned on YouTube you know why because
the guy who is resisting the the cops
those cops are breaking the law I'll put
it this way you should follow the law
those cops they broke the law yeah so
when when a bunch of criminals that's
what those people were they were petty
criminals assaulting somebody in a bus
who did nothing wrong
that wasn't an instance of
someone violating the law but you know
how YouTube's gonna interpret it mmm
Oh the cops are right of course oh but
if you you can't encourage people to to
you know to resist police you can't say
that you'll get banned so you you quite
literally have several instances where
police are breaking the law criminal
activity petty for sure it's like low
low assault & battery maybe they're
doing it they're the ones violating all
these quarantine rules you know what I
feel like this has always happened this
there's there's good cops and bad cops
out there and everybody's inside so ever
that so it's it's kind of like the
internet all over again because now
every everybody's seeing everything so
though the little things that happen
everyone's like whoa now we can see it
because there's nothing going on
anywhere I mean kind of but police
brutality was hugely viral over the past
decade
exactly and they've actually tried
shutting it down mm-hmm what I'm saying
is that proves my point even more
because if I make a video where I say if
a police officer tries to break the law
time
you should not abide by what they're
saying if I said that and told people to
do that I would be banned like that boom
gone so we're supposed to sit here and
take it as we see seeds get banned as
people get chased down the beach by cops
for no reason as people get dragged off
of busses for breaking no laws that's
not even arrested not even rice ed or or
a dad and his kid being you know get hit
the dad gets locked up
yeah dude paddle boarding by himself
they're asking for trouble
I'm not advocating for anything I'm
saying you're gonna people are gonna are
gonna put on Guy Fawkes masks and that's
not you don't march around it's not even
bringing into the conversation the read
flaw red flag laws totally and the
no-knock warrants that are getting
people killed innocent people getting
killed because they got the wrong house
that's why I'm saying it sounds crazy it
sounds like they're trying to make it
happen yeah you know what you notice it
just what bothers me more than anything
is inefficiency and the government right
now and typically is just so
ridiculously inefficient it's like I
can't stand watching someone with a you
know a square peg trying to jam it into
a round hole yeah like it's like nails
on a chalkboard to me and I'm being
sitting here being forced to watch this
and so you've got some people who think
it's more nefarious than that like there
must be something else going on I can
respect it but we don't have any
evidence to suggest that I'm just
looking at a bunch of really really dumb
people running around like chickens with
their heads cut off seems like I guess
we should ban seeds that seems like it's
a smart idea we should stop people from
running on the beach it's like who are
these you know what man it takes a
really really stupid person to enact
these kinds of rules or to think that
they're authoritarian decree will
actually solve the problems this is why
I hate government and I want have
anything to do with it
because everybody thinks they know the
answer everybody thinks that I know
here's the plan if we do X we will get Y
no you don't know that you have no idea
you're talking about a good plan no one
human can calculate all of the veils
that will come variables that will come
out of your stupid policies truth well I
guess we can just sit down and look
forward to the point when the government
you know Uncle Sam comes a-knockin and
set and says I want you to inject this
in your arm don't ask me what it is shut
up and persley are you saying no okay
fine you're not allowed out of your
house anymore sounds you're not allowed
in the public space right that's what
they're saying
yeah if you want it that's crazy work
you know what I think that's I think
they man I think it would be fair to say
it's a bit pre-emptive but about you
says we're talking about it I don't care
if it's Princip or not I think it's
important to talk about make sure
everybody knows they're talking about it
and if they want to do it I'll tell you
what no one's gonna do anything no one's
gonna say anything they're gonna be like
okay when he started saying all this
stuff and he started seeing you know
more like right libertarian types refuse
I like no way you get mainstream media
attacking them saying like you're you're
causing all these problems you know it's
really funny is like the fluoride thing
you know about fluoride mm-hmm
how it's like bad for you right to
ingest it right and we ingest it because
it's in our water well if you drink
water from the faucet right it's Florida
in it that does which I do not so
there's there's a couple arguments there
initially for the longest time I
remember you know like Alex Jones talked
about the stuff quite a bit but he often
you know layers things in a kooky way
so for the longest time fluoride if it's
good for your teeth that doesn't mean
you should swallow it yeah the argument
was
mainstream science saying the
concentrations in tap water were too low
to cause neurological impairment but
high enough to actually protect your
teeth and this is a really good thing
one of the arguments in the libertarians
was that it doesn't matter whether it
works or doesn't
you can't mass medicate the population
without their consent turns out a
collection of reports were put together
and I think this is by the National
Institute of Health finding that yep
guess what they found neurological
impairment from lifelong exposure to
fluoridated tap water not surprising
now don't look I'm not I'm not a
scientist so this was like it was an
aggregation of like 26 studies that each
found in various ways there was a slight
impairment due to drinking tap there was
a study a documentary I've watched about
ancient Egypt
Egyptians and the there's a gland in the
center of the brain piny lore and the
pineal gland if yet I think that's what
it is yeah and it's supposed to be like
where your soul resides so they believe
so they believe right you know it's all
hearsay essentially from what I
understand what they believe but it
turns out fluoride like mutes that gland
I don't supposedly again let's put it
this what it's interesting though you
know as as fairly skeptical people
mm-hmm this is the claim the claim is
that the pineal gland the third eye the
Gateway to the soul whatever they want
to call it yeah exactly is like
petrified or damaged or muted as a
florid I don't know if that's true I
don't know if it's true either but I've
seen the stories what I can't say I I
have read some articles a really long
time ago so it's even possible I'm
totally wrong about the fluoride thing
but they're still the argument from the
libertarians perspective is if that if
you're if you're saying it's good for
someone's teeth then why are you forcing
people like why are you putting in the
tap water so everyone drinks and bathes
in it yeah yeah you know that's like
people should have a choice right right
they shouldn't so I'll do it I'll tell
you what I'm not gonna be too keen on
them saying so so apparently I guess
this how it'll work once the instructor
start to die down they're taught the CDC
is saying that people have been exposed
cuz I coming back to work well how do
they know if you're cleared to go back
to work immunity cards so they'll test
you by swabbing the back of your like
you're you they go all the way back up
to your brain basic
with the q-tip and try and swab you know
get a sample I don't think it's the same
test that's the corona kovat test but
they want to do an antibody test to see
if you have the co vid 19 antibodies I
think that one will be a blood draw test
probably and if you do then you are
cleared hmm and if you don't you must
get your medicine from the government
I'm not too sure I would like them to
inject me with their quickly hastily
made injection by mandate you know and
here's the thing I got tons of shots
like I was saying before when I went to
Egypt and all that right like I don't
care it's like I'm really not worried if
they if it really was really really bad
you'd see adverse reactions maybe you
don't be you know if the people who want
to be the guinea pigs who get the first
shots you know you can do that but I'm
not super worried isn't that already
happening isn't there already but yeah
people are doing tests yeah yeah so some
it's it's some really weird is is is you
know going on it depending on where you
wait what you read you'll see a lot of
Trump supporters are saying you've got
hydroxychloroquine azithromycin and zinc
or some other combinations have been
anecdotally effective and you're seeing
this treatment used around the world yet
for some reason I can't tell you why
there's all these nonprofits and news
organizations trying to tell people not
to do it not to take it you got a
Democrat Michigan saying it saved her
life then I saw this journalists blue
cheeky tweeting out guidelines saying a
lot of people are taking this but here's
what you need to know it can kill you
and I'm like why are you who's not a
doctor right telling people not to take
this agenda the conspiracy theory is
that the pharmaceutical companies stand
to gain a massive massive amount of
money if the cute if the if the goal is
a vaccine instead of a cure okay it's a
conspiracy theory I'm not saying it's
true but I'll tell you what we're
dealing with capitalist America whatever
you want to call it I mean if I ran a
vaccine company or pharmaceutical
company I'd certainly be a lobbying like
the vaccine is the best way to do this
you know you know gotta worry about
reinfection we don't got to worry about
manufacturing the medicine in the future
and then yeah I think there's some fair
arguments for a vaccine but the the
argument now is that you know Trump is
interested in whatever will get the job
done and getting things going again
but big corporate interests want a
vaccine they can patent in control yep
that's true
yup especially if this virus is gonna be
around if it keeps mutating a little bit
just like the flu stays around yeah
though big flivver ever be in business
with a whole nother day everyone gets
the flu shots I mean I say everybody cuz
no I don't I don't either but I don't I
don't get the flu yeah it's weird you
know cuz that you're healthy you're you
stay fairly healthy this is the flu the
flu shot only works for a few strains
though right yeah they try to calculate
as best they can with scientists in
Australia cuz their flu season is before
ours really yeah that's why I half the
time does it work by the time it gets
here it's totally different that's why I
kind of just like what they're churning
them out there aren't thoughts those
shots I had to do it because I worked
with compromised populations and I
probably wouldn't do it otherwise cuz I
never get the flu I just don't want to
pass it on to somebody who doesn't
deserve it you know thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you